can I get the beef stew 10min you know
when people ask you like did you just
eat
I always just Dave so after we were done
dancing I wanted to take Ellen out to
eat you know as a thank you also to rest
myself in any fears because I dance my
ass off but this is place out in a
Monterey Park girl handbook called
Mandarin noodle house my personal
favorite Taiwanese beef noodle stew soup
I'm not sure if it's like like famous or
very well-known but they they're
Taiwanese beef noodle soup has really
don't had my noodles and it's my
personal favorite and there's this nice
little greasy film on top that fills
your body and soul makes a Dookie a
little bit but other than that quite
delicious
in Korea we call it tight on them I
guess it tastes a lot different from
ours so there's a lot of like Chinese
implants in Korea that kind of like
modify it to fit the Korean palate and
it's like a huge thing that we eat it's
like ink ready to get it to go all the
time try them in a novel which is tongue
soup which is all actually Chinese
modified for us but this is the Chinese
version
I asked Ellen to kind of mix the China
which is what you're supposed to do as a
judge even comes with that black bean
sauce on top is kind of supposed to
mixing them with nose oh that thing is I
mean oh never mind okay whatever you
want to do because your laser help you
do it I'm hungry you're a mother I
thought you liked doing that [ __ ] I hope
you burn everything your mom I think the
funniest part of us eating was the fact
that one of the waiters or the owners
were staring at the back of my head as I
look even the food of the whole time I
like their Mapo tofu spawned here yo
super
like a package one I did good I think
she was a prize she was like oh my god
all that food for one person well I only
have two like this in China I don't know
what just happened why more about L it
is just a weird character in general you
know if you guys ever have or if you've
no dancers your whole life you'll never
meet a legit dancer
that is quote unquote a normal human
being they're super energetic are off
the ball half the time I don't know what
the [ __ ] they're saying to me [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ]
Oh thirty pounds right now you want me
to yeah uh-huh
this is fo bettin to upset all the
grease now yeah yeah yeah I mean
basically during the meal she was giving
me [ __ ] about how unhealthy my food
choices were despite the fact that she
ordered half the [ __ ] menu herself
and she was eating it yeah I had a coke
with some of my greasy ass food we got
doing that you could if we do a quiche
hey well good luck
haha giving me pop so shield over here
Tippett tap and everybody stood oh
what's this oh what's that
don't do that to me away my damn mom how
about this you eat your food shut the
hell up
I love you Ellen maybe we're look you
got you got you get together to talk
about my seat
Ellen also has a child her name is kia i
call her kaya
because kaya sounds better Ellen ha ha
ha ha just kidding I keep on saying just
kidding as a buffet she's at her
it's just money GDP it's just my baby
but K is probably one of the cutest
little babies ever seen she's one of the
little black areion babies cute is [ __ ]
she dances super Lively
super cute I think she said mama - in
descent me bad
yeah you're welcome